so the video you're about to see is a
discussion I had with JP math so JP you
might have seen him on my channel I've
had a few clips where we're in a
discussion JP is part of a group of a
discussion that I have every month a
kind of private symbolism seminar for
patrons and JP is graduated he just
finished his degree in philosophy he's
very keen very smart he has had some
discussions with Paul van der clay with
also John Verve a key and so I was a
high time that I had him on my channel
you will see in the discussion that we
refer to some video that I put up as a
patron only video and because of that I
kind of hesitated to put up our
discussion because I thought some people
will be confused this patron video that
I put up which is kind of like a dive
into the laboratory of symbolism I now
considered making it public because it
has it has more views than I have
patrons if you can imagine that but it's
such a wild video and in there's so much
going on that I don't necessarily want
out in the public sphere that I don't
think I'm going to make it public at
least not for a while but nonetheless
even though there is some moments in the
video where where we refer to that I
think that in general you'll get a good
sense of some of the deeper discussions
that are happening in the realm of
symbolism how this relates to
consciousness how it relates to the way
in which nature reveals itself
you know just naturally so we talk about
the book of Ephesians st. Paul these
ontological levels there's a lot of good
stuff in there and I hope that I hope
that it'll be useful for everybody to to
follow this discussion
[Music]
this is Jonathan pezzo welcome to the
symbolic world
[Music]
you
[Music]
and so he has a lot of insight to give
and I thought it would be a great idea
to have him on the channel he also has
his own YouTube channel now where he's
looking especially at trying to use pen
psychism as a bridge between
Christianity and science you some of you
might have seen him on my channel live I
have posted a few clips with him as well
so JP maybe you can start we I maybe I
want to start right away and dive into
the subject because this morning I
tweeted something about the book of
Ephesians because yesterday at church I
there was the reading in the liturgy was
the the Epistle in the Liturgy was from
the book of Ephesians and it really
struck me I mean I knew the book I'd
read it several times but sitting you
know being in church sometimes it hits
you even more because you're surrounded
by everything and so it really hit me
that the book of Ephesians was a very
profound description of reality and
especially the way that we've been
looking at reality in terms of symbolism
and you know this hierarchy of beings
and how bodies and minds fit together
and so I tweeted something about it and
then JP right away answered with a video
that he had put up like yesterday was it
um less Freddie or less right next a few
days ago and and so I watched a video
and there in the video he talks about
Ephesians and how it's the best it's one
of the best books in the Bible that
talks about this destruction so maybe
you can dive right in there and and tell
us what you kind of came up with and
then we can start the discussion that
way yeah sure
especially I added in that video I was
especially talking about I was
delivering some ideas from Ganesha law
to figure out especially the
relationship in Ephesians where st. Paul
says that for instance wives be
submissive to your husbands so you have
the idea that the body is supposed to
submit to the head to the higher mind
but on the other end he also says that
the husband is supposed to lay his life
down for his first family so that the
head is supposed to sacrifice itself and
this really ties in well with ideas from
Anita who claims that well if you look
at any is 3 before Christianity any
society before Christianity the only way
for people to really come together was
to unite themselves against
someone dared to sacrifice the scapegoat
basically and that was the recurring
thing because it's not a stable
situation and then when after precursors
to this in the Old Testament but when
Christ himself came when God became
incarnate what he did what Christ was
present what Christ did was to imitate
the Father to submit himself to the will
of the Father
and to lay down his life for for the
church and this I mean I'm going through
this very quickly yes lots of people
I've heard about initial I know but the
basic idea is that Christ showed that
from the beginning of history when
people were uniting themselves against
the scapegoat they were really uniting
themselves against someone was innocent
was that was not there before
Christianity people generally thought
generally in religions before
Christianity before judeo-christian he
should say that when the people were
united against the scapegoat the Kurds
were building on the side of the
community because indeed after after the
community gather together in one mind
against the scapegoat because they did
really work the situation they actually
did call the situation it would create
unity amongst amongst the people yeah
yeah
so what afterwards people really do
think that well that person must have
been some sort of demon or some sort of
a bad good for for having had all that
our really - really cause that problem
to resolve it once we we kill that
person but when Christ died and then
resurrected he showed that God was not
on the side of the perpetrators of don't
those who crucified Him but was actually
on the side of the victim of the
scapegoat so this really forced people
to yes this showed this opened the eyes
of people that for all of history people
have been aligning themselves behind the
fundamentalist the the mind of Satan
yeah it had been uniting ourselves in
the body of Satan under the mind of
Satan but what Christ does is he reveals
that mechanism this was this was an evil
mechanism and also it shows the way out
of it and the way out of it is to
imitate Christ and to as I said submit
to the Father
so you emitted the father and what we
are supposed to be
Christ instead of trying to lower our
Amen to imitate or modular desires after
something earthly we are supposed to
model our desires after Christ models
themselves models desires after the
Father and we're also supposed to
sacrifice ourselves for our bodies in
the same way that Christ did for the
church and I forgot one thing in the
video and ties in with what we discussed
in our last patreon discussion a few
weeks ago yeah so I just say so some
people didn't I guess some people yeah I
put up I put it up as a patron only
video where it's a crazy video where JP
is there with me and we're talking about
like all this symbolism anyways I don't
want to go put too much into that it's
at last like an hour but I try to be
concise if you're gonna get that I'll do
my best
the part I missed in my video I realized
was the chart the charity um so know
when so okay so so Christ came from the
father came from heaven so he lowered
himself he sacrificed himself became man
became a sacrifice and then was raised
up but he also United people in charity
so when he was when he was human what we
did was to unite when he when he was
respected United people when he was the
arrived he was fragmenting people in
many ways setting
brother against brother against son yeah
and so on but when after his
resurrection people start to come
together especially in the church and
simple relieve stresses charity for this
and I think this this ties in really
well with a deep metaphysical fact I
think that ok so it seems the way no
with this seems to work is for something
to to hold together well let's see the
church to all together for the for the
earth really tool together you need okay
you need to model yourselves after the
desires of the father so after God need
to imitate and you need to follow DDD I
or mind
yeah so you need to follow that and you
then you sacrifice yourself for the
people you're responsible for for your
body but
in that body that body works in charity
okay
so there's also so there's a there's a
vertical relationship and those who
follow the videos will heard me say that
quite a while like that
there's who there's there's submission
coming from below and love coming from
above where you sacrifice is a good way
to understand it as well since that you
give yourself and you kind of empty
yourself for that which is below but
then across let's say amongst the the
body in the body itself there is also
it's through this conjoining and love
that st. Paul talks about in Ephesians
the fitting of the parts of the body
together and this working in love and
that is also it's also a aspect of that
very process of the vertical
relationship yeah it's all coming
together so and this is what is
happening in in eating and that that's
the link I want to to to to make to your
video to our discussion rather when
let's say I am I am one I am a higher
being when I'm let's I am eating an
apple am bi being and then there's an
apple okay for me to eat the apple all
of my cells have to work in one they
have to work in charity pretty much they
have to you know some cells get some
chemicals the other receive them there's
there's a whole army in my in my body
which is working in harmony okay and
then when I when I eat the apple I will
I will ferment it I start by chewing by
chewing on it and keep the it goes into
my my stomach and it keeps fragmenting
and crucially there's a point where yeah
I don't want to go too much into the
right and left hand but I think it's
worth talking about rigor and mercy yeah
just this when I'm okay when I'm
fragmenting the Apple I'm applying
bigger on it I'm not accepting it I'm
just keep breaking it down yeah I keep
breaking it down you're it's like yeah
and I'm just on myself I keep mercy I
just keep keep together working as one
unit but there is a point where in order
for me to digest the Apple I actually
have to do some some work or some
sacrifice there's a third part of myself
which aren't going to give away some
molecule
they're gonna give away some parts of
them maybe even full sell that I don't
know we'll go and finish dissolving the
Apple to keep breaking it down so add
that there's a fact a cursor so at the
beginning I was just applying rigor on
the Apple version myself there is a
point where in order for me to digest
the Apple I have to start applying rigor
on myself as well where I separate part
of myself and after this node escaped
remains in the Apple and then the flip
continues where then note that the Apple
is is dissolved enough and will absorb
the some parts of it I will apply mercy
on ya so and then my body will come
we'll keep working in harmony in order
to spread that that energy my cells will
keep working in charity you know to
spread all that that energy all that
good stuff and I will ultimately excrete
you know the remainders of the Apple
with what I have sacrificed the
molecules that I've sacrificed so
there's a thing that happens in two
levels where initially I was just it was
just rigor on the side of the Apple and
mercy on myself at some point I have to
apply rigor myself and then I'm able to
apply mercy on on the Apple Apple in
order to absorb it yeah so there's the
yeah I think that donor for for for a
unity to to Center into communion with
another unity or you you have to
dissolve 1 into multiplicity and then at
some point you yourself the unity has to
give something away to become multiple
so that it can keep from eating the
other one and then the and that the
multiplicity can be integrated into the
the first unity and I think there is
something similar going on with I think
this works at at many level so we can
see this in Genesis I think when okay so
initially there's God creates the given
in the earth and ultimately the the link
will be I think the same way that
I am eating the Apple you want Evan to
eat the earth you want the evidence to
inform yes that's really important it's
important to understand that that's also
where the sacrifice is a sacrifice when
you burn the meat and it goes up like
the smoke goes up into the heavens it's
an image of heaven eating the earth like
a or smelling it they usually use the
word smelly but it's in its integrating
it's bringing into itself
yeah and so I think this is what was
going on before the fall where okay so
God separated
he created the earth and intervening the
earth is one it's just one one ball of
chaos and then God keep separating it
yeah so the earth keeps separating and
then you will put man in such a place
that there can be an enormity in charity
between all of the species all that
would exist on the earth and crucially
there's a point where the man will will
will work will do a sort of sacrifice or
yes to tend to the garden yes - actually
he has to give away some source of
energy so that you can then take the
fruits of the garden the fruits of
creation really and unite them and turn
them - to the father to the iron mine so
you have the same pattern as we did with
eating where what Adam does is he
modeled himself after all of creation is
like our cells it's working all together
and it's all following the higher mind
it's all following Evan and crucially
there's a point of it there was a point
in all of that that creation working
charity there's a point of it which will
have to sacrifice that's what Adam and
Eve do when they attempt to the garden
and indeed and then they get to eat a
bit - they sacrifice themselves and then
they there's a sort of resurrection
where they get to reap the rewards of
their work and that towards God so there
are many there you you think it makes
sense so far because well I I think I
think I understand I think there's
something makes sense I think that we
have to account for the fact that work
comes after the fall like it's not clear
the difference between tending and the
in Genesis narrative and then that in
the fall is when God says that you'll
have to work in order to receive but I
think
that I think that the main let's say
that the main I think that if we see it
in a cosmic vision like if we see it in
a cosmic vision and that's sometimes
hard to see but if we see it in the
whole story it seems like that's what
happened that in fact although the fall
is a scandal the fall participates in
the whole process of bringing all into
God you know ultimately that's like so
so man falls down and starts to give
have to give of himself let's say as
he's as he's falling down all the way to
Christ which who gives themselves
completely and then everything gets
gathered back up and goes in and so so
there is there is sometimes a even
inside here Aeneas you do get a bit of a
sense that the fall is a kind of
pedagogical thing that although we won't
say that God wanted us to fall that he
cut he knew it was gonna happen that it
was it was part of a larger story that
we don't totally understand or even
maybe maybe it turned out you know
especially after the fall that the
sacrifices had to get larger and larger
ultimately in Christ but even before the
fall when they say Adam is created
there's some work there I mean it's like
but God does yep yes gathered here and
there's for sure there's work because
then it says God rested so for sure
there's an analogy to work in creation
itself that is that is for certain and
so it so there isn't me you could maybe
just we could just call it a different
of levels probably between before the
fall and after the fall and I think it's
also because in after the fall the way
it's presented is that it's like it's a
it's an upside-down process where man
becomes a slave to work like he becomes
a slave to to the lower things rather
than you know kind of voluntarily
engaging let's say with creation so
maybe that's the best way to understand
it yeah now that makes sense I think
that I think that I think it makes a lot
of sense for people who who are kind of
we're kind of not maybe totally
following the discussion the idea that
I've been presenting
if you follow my videos you've heard me
say something similar for a while the
idea is that this image of Christ and
the Last Judgment and Christ bringing
things towards himself and pushing
things away from himself what I've been
trying to kind of propose is that that
is an actually an image of how reality
works it's not just an image of the Last
Judgment it's an image of the totality
of being and so everything has
everything that exists has an outside
and an inside has a margin and a center
and therefore if there is a a process by
which it integrates things and it
rejects things and that that that
bringing in and pulling out seems to be
the manner in which the world works and
so we see Christ talked about it so when
you start to understand that when you
understand that let's say eating is an
analogy to the Incarnation then you can
understand things like when Christ says
that that we that st. Peter is going to
be a fisherman a Fisher of men that he's
going to fish for men right and so and
and and so you can imagine so so Peter
says in the boat and he goes and he
tosses in his net and he pulls up human
beings out of the water in order for God
to eat them
you know that's what it is in order for
them to become God's body and so you
know all the imagery of the fish in
Christianity seems to relate to that the
idea that we are I mean you can use it
the Bible mostly uses sexual imagery in
terms of being United with God but you
can also use the imagery of eating and I
think that for sure of fish has to do
with that when he says that that Peter
is going to be fishing for men it's like
bringing them out of the chaos lifting
them up in order that for them to become
an aspect of the body of God yeah yeah
and I think there's something that can
help with the Trinity there as well you
have the yeah the one which you have the
iron mind and then you have part at some
in the body mm-hmm then some part of it
will have to sacrifice then as it's
reborn there will be charity across that
body that body will actually work yes
you have really like the Father the Son
and then
do ya do it yeah and in Ephesians say
st. Paul traces it he says he actually
traces lists like three-dimensional
cross in his description easy says he
says the height the width and the
breadth of the love of God and so if you
can imagine it as like as an actual as
an as a say a spatial system with an
accent and two to two horizontals like
yeah he seems to really be talking about
the shape of reality in Ephesians
everybody has to read Ephesians when
they're done with this video
yes Patricius is so short and you can
help with yeah I mean I just watched
your video with genre Reiki today and of
course I watched of it I rewatched
several times part of it yeah but and
this can help with relevance realization
as well I think you have the the one
which as to yeah yeah it's still easy in
my mind but I think there's something
there you know you have the one you have
the Father who creates okay something
who sees all the possibilities in it all
the multiplicity and who has to send his
son to bring it all together in love
towards the father there it's it seems
to be out reality works I mean it worked
with eating it worked with Genesis and I
mean we could give tons of examples it
seems to me how everything works
no I think so I totally agree I think
that I think that I really do think that
the book of Ephesians really describes
how how how reality works and how
because this has been the problem the
the big problem that we've been having
that not just you but a lot of people
are having is to understand how reality
moves up the levels how how it is
possible for things to exist at
different levels of reality now you know
and so and so it seems like this type of
thinking that this notion of sacrifice
from above the idea of submission from
below and also the gathering and you
know the the the the joining in love
seems to be the one of the best ways to
understand how things jump or move up
levels into ontological hierarchy you
know so how so how you have a person
that is joined you know
that is made out of all these parts all
these different thoughts all these
different feelings all of this and/or
then and then how people come together
in order to in order to draw and join to
form larger groups and to form bodies in
terms of communities and stuff yeah and
of course this ties in with and psychism
especially when you start talking about
how people come together as all where
and you've talked about passions a bunch
of times on your channel but ideally you
know a person just just for you to exist
correctly as as one you need to have all
your passions oriented in charity do
they all have to work together correctly
new pressures aren't necessarily bad
it's bad fall to them but if they're
liquid if they're organizing charity
yeah and for it but for this weapon for
for all of your passions to be
subordinate to your pure mind to the art
principle you will have to sacrifice
some parts of yourself for sure yeah no
exactly and that that is exactly the the
you know when we talk about rigor and
mercy this is where it all it all falls
in is that those the pulling in and the
pushing out is always happening
simultaneously so like when you talked
about eating the Apple it's like in
order to integrate the apple the Apple
has to lose some of its idiosyncrasies
or else it won't be integrated you know
and that's the same with any anything
like our friendship is the same you know
too if you want to be friends with
someone as you kind of come closer to
that other person you have to give up
some of your idiosyncrasies you know the
common space to appear you know if you
just and you can see it like people who
are who are stubborn and just hold on to
their thing then they struggle to be in
teams or they struggle to be to be in in
a relationship and so you know it's like
you have to find that sweet spot between
having a kind of integrity you know like
this kind of integrity that you want to
have about yourself but then also being
in a relationship with and giving up
some things in order to enter it in
communion with someone else and that's
that seems that play that interplay
between with between you know bringing
in pushing away seems to be like you
said on the horizontal skier that seems
to be the way that we interacted with
friends and with family and everything
and that's how we kind of conjoined
together and then it's it also ends up
being the same and how we form something
hire like how we formed the body of
Christ for example is that that very
process is the manner in which we also
are sacrificing our idiosyncrasies as a
group in order to manifest this higher
purpose it's our thing and one way maybe
one thing maybe is it's that us being
united in charity together we can make
space for this our principle for God to
yeah
to sacrifice himself for us this is what
happens at every master divine liturgy
to sacrifice himself for us so that we
can better come together on the rim so
there's really work done by the eye or
principle there there can't just be so
charity across for the unity to work
even even I mean you can take more
examples like my cells my soul scans
just exists as they know as a bunch of
so they have to be united under under me
and I have to work on a cell for it if
you put if we take your all yourself put
them in a blender
yes sir there's really a place for the
our principle for the other mind and
yeah so we make space for that every
time you go to church for Divine Liturgy
really yeah and I think that that's I
think that that's the the most important
thing that comes out of this and this is
also something that I talked about in
the with John for Vicki today is is the
idea that we have to be careful not to
see it only one direction right is it so
the let's say the modernists right now
when they talk about this and talk about
complex systems they only want to talk
about emergence they only want to talk
about this the lower process and for me
it's funny cuz I'm I'm actually now
discovering the other part because I was
all top-down from before like I was all
the plainest you know it's a crazy
plainness and so and so now it's like I
I know I'm I'm happy you actually to
have discovered this because now I can
kind of see the importance of the of the
conjoining and love but you can't it
can't just be that like you said that
there also has to be and I think the
idea of the sacrifice is a great idea
there's also something which has to come
down from below and be willing to come
down and manifest itself in in in a body
you know and so and that's the same like
if you think about if you think about
team let's say
let's say you're you have a purpose it
could be anything let's say you're
you're you're gonna you're managing a
project and you have a logos you have a
Telos you know you have a purpose you
have a reason why you're together and so
it's the same it's like that reason it
it also can't be completely pure like it
can never be it can't it can't remain
completely sharp it has to mitigate like
it has to kind of fall into the
specifics of the people who are and it
has to be pliable enough in order to
accept that the difference is that the
you know the fact that this is like if
it was made by another team in the end
the final result might look different
then then this team you know so and so
the purpose has to have enough give
enough back in order for it to be able
to to reach its goal you know if the if
the goal is so tight then it's then it
won't the let's say that the joining of
heaven and earth won't happen you know
the goal will remain aloft and will
never reach it because it's too it's
just too tight does that make sense
don't I don't need to see God that
there's one part I'll one thing that
came to mind was that for the abstract
idea is for the plan of the coach who
manifests itself in the players is it
taking the players into account yeah it
has to some somehow enter into that
multiplicity it has to reach down to a
point where I mean the course electric
to say it as an individual he has to say
say the pan to all the players so the
plan can become incarnate through and
yeah through some sort of work my the
other principle to the coach has to know
think about the idea I was gonna say it
I was gonna put it this one and then not
just that he has to understand like I
have this player I have this player this
player and and so if I like this is how
I can do it considering the fact that I
I have this body like this is the body
that I have if if I if I if I design a
play that cannot you know held by this
body then it's gonna fail even if it's
the best play in the world but if I
don't have what I need in the body to
accomplish it it's not going to it's
going to play so there there has to be
like you said work coming from down from
above and from below
yes oh so those two things together that
seems like that seems to be what and so
the identities in the world let's say
like any identity like a like a maple
you know you know it has enough
pliability so that the maple can exist
in different places like it but there's
a limit right there's a limit there's a
there's a there's a scale and so the the
maple can exist in certain types of soil
but there's a enough multiplicity for it
to exist but then at some point at some
point it stops like you can't if you
plant a maple in the tundra it's not
gonna grow right it's just not gonna
grow but there is there is a there is
the identity of maple isn't so so tight
that you can only plant a maple you know
in on 10 square feet of the world and if
you if it's not in that exact precise
thing then it's gonna be a great it's
gonna be the greatest tree ever like
probably ever it has to be planted in
this 10 foot zone and on the entire
Earth and they are else it's not gonna
grow like that's not this isn't work
it's not gonna happen it has to be this
play I don't that make sense that I'm
bringing it down to maples but I'm just
trying to see how it how this works on
all the different levels of reality yeah
and I don't if we ready to talk about
the flip but I I'd like to try at least
alright we could try it's just that I
think we have to lay down some ground a
little bit in terms of of what with the
concept is so did you want you or you
should try to I don't help me see if you
understood what I talked about okay we
have to explain it first I can't explain
what the idea is of the inversion oh
yeah like for people that we were
watching yes well it's in the digest and
first all right okay then I'll try to
talk about the angels all right okay
that sense can exist anywhere in our
conversation so digestion then I'm gonna
say uh the level of full objects like
human or Apple no I'm just applying
record at the ice level initially before
I start eating and
supplying rigor and it's only at the
lower level once once I reach the level
of maybe not even cells but molecules
when I give away some of my molecules
this is the point where the de mercy and
the rigor slip where I will apply rigor
to myself instead of applying rigor to
the Apple to keep the echo wait I mean I
chew on it but it still is still awaits
not it's not in me really until I flip
at the level of my sons and my molecules
and I give some of me away I separate
myself and then this will keep
fragmenting the Apple it's still rigor
on it and then it slips also on the side
of the Apple where I start to apply
mercy on on the Apple and I will bring
it into myself or integrate it yeah so
the so the so the flip occurs once I
reach a low enough level so this may be
why in India I come you should that's in
the iconostasis nobody knows what you're
talking about you have to let me just
let me just laid it down for me you know
my my my contention is that one of the
reasons why we don't understand the move
of different ontological levels is
because we only want to understand it as
like a coherent relationship between the
two levels but my contention is that it
seems like there's actually a flip that
happens where what is above actually
turns for what is below like a mirror
something like that and so and so and
it's related to the idea of it's like a
change of perspective where if I'm
standing in front of you if I if like
when we shake hands we cross over so my
right hand goes across and your right
hand comes and meets me and so it seems
like that which is pushing away from me
and pulling towards me on above ends up
flipping upside down below and so that's
what john phillip is talking about when
he says it's like if i'm eating the
Apple at first I'm breaking it down I'm
fragmenting it right and and and but
then at some point there's a change
where I have to I have to now gather it
into myself right so there's this flip
that happens at some point so maybe I go
ahead from there because yeah and and it
happened as we went down the hierarchy
of being
yeah some point what what for me to al
ultimately Mercian on the opponent eat
it there has to be a flip at the level
of the cells where this said this is the
level where finally I can yeah I have to
have rigor on myself in order to be able
to have mercy on on the Apple this
happened at the level of the cell could
happen couldn't couldn't have happened
just my my level of me JP so you have
the the our principle for the IRA prince
fought to ultimately eat the apple you
need to to ultimately for the our
principle to ultimately really
assimilate the other unity you are you
will need to have mercy on it at some
point but this does not occur occur at
the scale of of the whole human it's all
good at lower scale and this may be what
happened gives it in in some some icons
you will have for instance Saint Michael
on one side who is on the side of a
rigger yeah there's a weapon generally
and then on the other side yeah st.
Gabriel who has the some sort of flower
who is on the side of mercy and then
there'll be icons work so you should
have a safe Michael st. Gabriel then you
have Christ in the middle and then
Christ will be judging the the goat and
the Sheep
and so you would expect it see if sign
to my call the de rigueur
is here you would expect him to be over
the the goats the goats here and will
get thrown away you would expect rigor
to cast away it goes if people have to
be familiar with which revelation to to
understand this no it's the tribulation
no it's a crime in the Gospels when a
Christ saying yeah I think yeah okay
yeah so you would expect the the angel
of rigor to be over the sheet and you
would expect conversely go to yeah sorry
the content you can receive you would
expect the angel of mercy namely Gabriel
to be over the Sheep but it's actually
flipped in in the images yeah and this
may be because in at the level of angels
in heaven this is the DD higher level
and
the clip occurs through Christ through
the India analogy with the body it could
be like the the rigor and mercy would be
the angels at the level of the whole
human then the flip occurs at the level
of myself and then you would have the
molecules inversed so you would have
let's say that you're ultimately
advocating is is for some kind of Apple
purgatory I think is what you're
advocating for the purgatory of apples
just like oh man where did you go with
all right but I I'm hoping people can
fall I'm gonna show I will I'll show the
icon so people can see this this this
flip but but yeah so but I think you
wanted to try to apply to something that
you would I guess is that where you
wanted to apply it to angels that's the
that's the point
yeah yeah there was no point where I
think that's the reason why the angels
are slipped in in the feast so my
constants not not always as you know one
of the first image we have of the Last
Judgement that's what is there in Ravana
you see you see the red angel on the
side of the Sheep and then the blue
angel on the side of the goats and I was
always been very annoyed about that but
then I think I finally understood that
there's this there's this cross and
there are many places in scripture where
you see this crossing over you you see
it in the the blessing of the blessing
of Joseph of Jacob who blesses Joseph's
children and he crosses his hands like
this when he does a blessing and even
you know Joseph like uncross his hands
but then he crosses them again he's like
no this is how it has to go like I have
to cross over so there's this this this
this sense of this this flip that
happens you know at the different levels
of being yeah and maybe we can see if
you see if the pattern works also in the
incarnate the Incarnation see with okay
so let's say we take still still even in
earth as before the fall and we try to
see how Christ will come to play take
the place which Adam add so I guess the
the idea would be
that night rest worthy yeah in order for
Evan to eat the the earth within
rebellion who is not aligned with not
working in in charity yeah you needed
God to become Oh probably worse with
with the we have we have to talk about
Israel somehow Israel has to fit
somewhere in there so let's say you have
in creation yeah maybe instead of
talking about species we should talk
about different groups of humans
different cities or different tribes and
among them you have Israel so Israel has
been good as good has been merciful
towards Israel and as separated it from
from the others so good has been sort
applying rigor on the other separated
and having mercy on Israel but it will
flip with Christ that's why Paul says at
least it seems to say that's what
happens yeah I mean God will have rigor
in Israel it will sacrifice part of
Israel it will sacrifice Christ yeah
in order to add mercy ultimately I want
everybody else yeah
so the cry yeah so the Jews will
sacrifice Christ will sacrifice
Israel and the whole world will
sacrifice Christ then you will die be
cast away and then as he as he comes
back to life this is sort of like when a
city in the body when the the molecule
which was given away or they saw which
was given away so he's created back
again maybe their ability to do their
but yeah the one who stressed it too
much but then then when when Christ
comes back he will unite ultimately the
the whole world yeah well there's a text
in Saint Paul I think I think it's in
Romans where he talks about he tells the
Romans be who are the poor the pagans
and who will ultimately become the image
of the church itself like even all
churches model themselves on Rome he
says that you know Christ is the tree
you are the branches yeah you have been
added so the Jews have been cut off
you have been added in so you've been
brought in and there they have been
pushed away and he says but don't boast
of that like don't don't don't think
it's it's to you because who's to say
that one day God will not cut you off
and then bring back the the Jews and and
then he says so that no one so that no
one can boast and so that all can be
saved that's it he that's where he says
the same it's like okay okay man that's
like I've been thinking about this text
for so long I'm trying to understand
this relationship between this bringing
in pushing out and dissing virgin that
happened because to me this was this was
I mentioned this in the patron video it
to me this is also about understanding
the story of Christianity because there
are some very strange things that happen
in the story of Christianity one is
exactly that one is you know the Romans
are the bad guys in the in the story
especially in in the in the gospel the
Romans are the bad guys they're the
they're persecuting Israel they're
putting false gods in a temple they're
you know they're trying to to take over
and then it flips and so Rome becomes
Christian we're all Rome follows Christ
and then it's like this so it's like
this weird inversion and in Romans in
the story of Christianity itself there's
also this inversion in the sense that
you get Christianity enters into the
Roman into the Roman world through the
lower caste like through the slaves
through women through people who have
nothing so those are the ones who were
Christians for like three centuries and
then finally suddenly like all of a
sudden it flips and then it becomes the
emperor who converts so it's like it's
full so it moves from being like a not
only it was the only religion in I think
I think I think mani key ISM and
Christianity were the only religions
that were outlawed in in Rome and so you
have so you have the many the mana keys
and you have the Christians who demand
keys also were kind of weird Christians
like they they were they were heretic
but they is they kind of saw themselves
as fallen Christ somewhat whatever I
don't want to argue that we're here but
but so so they go from being the
complete outside to then becoming the
religion of the Empire I mean that flip
is crazy like that
crazy flip and it I think that it's once
we start to understand how these flips
occur there there are so many keys that
that so many ways that people see the
world which is wrong like they they when
sometimes you hear people argue in terms
of history they'll argue something for
example in terms of Israel they'll say
things like for sure Israel was
influenced by Mesopotamia mister potamia
could not have been influenced by Israel
because Mesopotamia is the Empire and
Israel was this little thing that had no
power it's like you know what actually I
don't think it works that way you know
what I don't think it works that way
because we have an example and it's our
example and it's Christianity where this
marginal foreign religion suddenly
flipped and then became the religion of
the Empire
why don't you think that it could has
happened before like why is it that the
only time in all the history of humanity
where that happened I don't think so
yeah and this I don't know if I'm
William do something with my Apple thing
but yes seems to be what happened there
where you know what was just the Apple
was ultimately what was what kid what
just kept getting prime minted and
multiplied was ultimately integrated and
became you know your body part of me
really really became part of me can't
you like it became your your incarnation
like everything that you are had went
through that process yeah it's like your
whole body is was at some point food
like it had to that go through that
process in order for you to exist yeah
and I really had to sacrifice part of
myself to actually digest that so Israel
which had been chosen so like Ezra was
chosen to ultimately integrate the whole
world back into into heaven so it's not
surprising that you know initially God
had mercy on Israel it sort of kept it
separate and the same way that maybe I
kept I keep someone I mean some my
listen I just stem cells
I keep themselves I keep them apart from
from the airpo I keep them actually hey
I think we we do some we'd probably do
some special things in order to keep the
problem fresher somehow but you I add to
isolate them and then at some point I
give them away so that the whole thing
can actually be anymore
the whole organism can be united so it
really feels there what what looked like
mercy and you don't mean really being
careful with myself actually turned out
to be no that's appointed that to turn
into rigor so that I could estimate the
whole Apple itself right yeah yeah yeah
no I I mean I think I think that I
definitely think that this is that I'm
hoping other people are gonna start to
think about this because it's hard to
think about but I do think that this
could really be yeah could help people
not just in terms of religious thinking
we you're using a lot of religious
imagery because that's what we care
about but I think that in terms just in
terms of understanding the the jump
between the different levels of reality
I think that understanding that exchange
can can be useful and we see it I mean
that's he talks about it in his book to
a certain extent and I just feel like
I've intuitively understood it very
recently and so I'm pretty excited about
about about that discussion um so yeah
so I mean I think people should
definitely in the comment section go
wild and and we'll try to be involved in
the conversation what's great about
these videos is that all the all the all
the trolls they don't watch these videos
like watch the they watch movies you
know the Joker video that's when they
watch her but but this video would be
only people that actually care about
this stuff that I watch it's a week I
expect a really great discussion in the
comment section and it seems really to
fit I think with again to come back with
okay and just keep coming back on so
with your conversation with Chandra
Vicki today because you have on some
point you have you need okay so there
are two extremes in creation there's
there's Evan and then there's the earth
you're just very potential initially and
it has to be separated has to be
multiplied to be taken up into into Evan
and fits well I think with reverse
realization that what is invisible the
IR the one has to sacrifice yes has to
do some work as to sacrifice as it
becomes part of the multiplicity as it
reaches all the way down to the most
fundamental grounded possibility so that
it can tend then take it back
yeah the taking back up I think is
really the Christian version because if
you look at at most most systems not all
but most systems they tend to see that
process of the higher coming into the
lower as in itself of a fall like in
itself a kind of degrading of the higher
principle and so you know Gnosticism
even in hinduism and and so you see this
idea that it's like the the lower beings
are less like they they're they're less
but I think what Christianity brings in
what Christ shows is actually this
process is the manner by which the
entirety is brought back up into the one
like that's the the actual process of of
how things are brought into are brought
into God and so it it ends up giving
value to the to the littlest one it ends
up giving value to the smallest you know
India to the extent that it's able to to
join together in love and participate in
this process so it's I think it I think
that that's one of the things that
Christianity really does offer to to
this to this question because we do run
the problem every time and I see it cuz
people are afraid when I talk about
hierarchy and I understand why they're
afraid they they they're they have a
certain reason to be afraid because
hierarchy can be a dangerous thing and
he can it can be a reality which which
is sees the only the idea of the lower
as serving the higher and I think or
then cut or then or then if you if you
don't accept that then you end up having
is constant revolutionary thinking where
you're always trying to break up the
higher break it up break it up break it
up you reach at the end of that I think
we've reached the end of that pretty
much in terms of thinking we're like
okay like now we're in this chaotic mush
of thing we don't have we don't were
losing the qualities we're losing the
identities we're losing the things that
brings together and so we need to find
them again but we need to do it in a way
that won't that won't that won't be just
a sword coming down from heaven you know
yeah cuz there because I know that's at
what some people actually want that's
not what we want
that what I want yeah we have to keep in
mind that also the sacrifice wasn't
arbitrary there
times when Christ's angers a bunch of
people and then he runs away and guess
what he chose the moment where he had to
sacrifice and stuff like you know when I
listen I am I'm eating actually I don't
sacrifice your severy thing to dissolve
the Apple yeah I suppose is the right
thing so that I can actually come back
together it's not trivial for what
allows people to actually come together
no there and there seems to only be as
what as jihad would say there there
seems to be only one way for people to
actually come together look for for good
in a way that won't just fragment again
and it has to be towards the D is it has
to come with the help of the is showed
us that way otherwise it just keeps
fragmenting again towards that other
words that do that we don't get the yeah
the right point to yes we don't serve
the fact what is the good sacrifice it
seems very very narrow that's what
Christ says anyways yeah right he tells
us that the path is narrow hmm
all right Jeff yep I think we've given
people quite enough to think about and
and so that wasn't too crazy yeah I
think it probably was too crazy but
that's okay that's okay I can handle a
little bit of crazy and so and so I
thought I would tell people that you
need to go check out JP's channel I will
put the link in the description where
you'll find his discussions his own
discussions and then his discussions
with other people as well it's well
worth your time and and we'll probably
end up doing this again I'm pretty sure
pretty sure thank you Jonathan
alright and thank you for your time John
for it there's a lot of great stuff
going on in the past few months there
are a few new songs by tumour V's some
duets with Jordan Peterson that you can
check out I'll put a link to that in the
description there's also I've been
having a lot of fun designing some new
t-shirts and merchandise trying to use
symbolic imagery and some symbolic
thinking in a way that I find
interesting
I'm basically designing the t-shirts
that I wish I could have had when I was
in my 20s and so check that out I'll put
a link to that as well and thanks to
everybody for your support and I will
talk to you soon
[Music]